years we're taking a closer look at the
midterm elections in our series issues
that matter control of the Senate hinges
in part on a race in Missouri Democratic
Senator Claire McCaskill is locked in a
close contest with the state's attorney
general Josh Holley Missouri voted for
President Trump in 2016 and has grown
more conservative over time CBS News
contributor Steve Inskeep who's also
host of NPR's Morning Edition and up
first took a road trip to learn what's
on voters minds he stopped for three
meals with Missouri voters Steve good
morning hey good morning we wanted to
see how the election relates to people's
lives and since you get to know people
when you share a meal we had breakfast
in a small town lunch in a suburb and
dinner in a city all in one day along
historic route 66
[Music]
we started before dawn in the small town
of Cuba Missouri at Shelly's route 66
Kevin hi are you Shelly Hey
we're friends gather and strangers are
made to feel welcome you mind if I sit
down
oh you vote on who sits would you like -
well it's election time these small
business owners veterans and retirees
are you retired or support the president
I think president Trump is doing the
best job you can do we have the best
economy we've ever had those sue Green
Street is feeling dread she's on
Medicare if they put everyone on
Medicare we seniors will be next in the
line for the head across the table Diane
nickel fears social unrest
the American citizens they decided to
either beat one side or the other I
think that that is just when you say
riots what riots this town is decorated
with murals showing famous moments in
the town's history like in 1864 battle
during the Civil War this is a town that
knows something about a divided country
we're going to get a different
perspective on this divided state as we
continue along historic route 66
continue on historic u.s. 66 east for
three miles which we will do as we're
heading from a red area of the map to a
blue area of the map so we're driving
into st. Louis County to Ferguson where
Michael Brown was killed by a police
officer in 2014 Kathy and Jerome Jenkins
kept their restaurant open during the
protests that followed today the street
has recovered and the Jenkins would like
to see more black owned businesses so
many papers are so many things you've
got to do there's so many taxes you have
to file every month it's like the system
is made to be different you sound like a
Republican too many taxes too many days
it sounds like I mean if they reached
out to you in a certain way they could
appeal to you I'm the lawyer you want
everything that I think a Republican
can't help it doesn't sound like we a
few things
just not their view of Obamacare which
cut the Jenkins insurance costs they
want to elect a Democratic Congress to
stop the president's attacks on it but
he's doing things I cannot even to speak
about because I can't it's getting along
late in the day we're moving slowly on
the interstate with traffic as far ahead
as I can see those red taillights but we
are on our way into the city of st.
Louis for dinner laughs Lee taproom
occupies a historic brick building what
would you recommend
flight attendant Janet Wayne didn't vote
in 2016
bartender shave and era did what's he
done that was better than you expected
he has I believe created jobs but there
is this you think global warming is a
huge problems yeah yes it's already
affecting us right now I mean we're
having record the President Trump as you
may know once called climate change
a Chinese hoax and more recently said
okay it's not a hoax but it's not
actually created by people and the
scientists have a political agenda
over at the bar this progressive couple
favors Democrats but they know much of
their conservative state will not what
would you want someone on the other side
of the divide to understand about you
that you think maybe they don't quite
get I think this isn't a zero-sum world
that we live in and it doesn't have to
be that way and yet it seems as though
it is if I have a primary motivator
it's that everyone's lives should be
better not just mine everyone's
[Applause]
and we find out soon which party gets
their voters to show up in Missouri and
by the way President Trump rallies
Republicans in the state twice before
Election Day Gale all right Steve I
really loved that piece nicely done
thank you you're welcome always good to
see you Steve always good to have you on
the program I love the last voter guys
who says everyone's life should be
better not just mine everyone's life
should be better we are all looking for
some of that right if Democrats can't
hold on to Missouri there's no way they
will be able to retake the Senate that's
why that seat is particularly important
Trump won that say looking forward to
election night will be year